it's commendable to create a compelling
video game world it's even more
impressive if that world has its own
history but it is downright astonishing
when that history actually effects how
we play a game and after 45 hours with
Ghost Recon breakpoint I can confidently
say this is one of those worlds the
South Pacific archipelago or OA is
saturated with personality and secrets
it's filled with remnants of a fictional
past and nods to an uncertain future in
a game with glaring systemic issues and
a poor scripted narrative I still can't
help but marvel at the way breakpoints
century spanning story is intertwine
with its gameplay and despite my
frustrations I'm obsessed with every
detail yes breakpoint is undoubtedly a
departure from the series roots but it
actually nails the idea of recon more
than some of its predecessors this is
due in large part to its intricate world
provided you play with exploration mode
enabled the majority of your time will
be spent gathering Intel scouting new
locations and mapping the archipelago
not only does this slow burn exploration
reinforce the sense that you're being
hunted in an unfamiliar land
it also helps add variety to your
playthrough my mo and wild lands was to
clear every outpost that came across but
in break point I'm conditioned to
prioritize information above anything
else I'm satisfied to enter a base
eliminate only immediate threats and
leave once I have new Intel in a sense
I'm dictating my own fun as I adapt to
the surroundings and it's this world's
backstory that helps me flesh out that
fun while I'm hacking computers stealing
documents helping civilians and
interrogating soldiers I'm also peeling
back numerous layers of environmental
storytelling on a massive scale the more
Explorer or OA the more I become
entangled in its fictional past so the
way I see it or OA comprises five
distinct let's call them chronological
strata to use an overly complicated term
first off is the islands immediate
present a state-of-the-art settlement
built by the tech giants tell in an
effort to create a utopia it's an
architectural portmanteau of brutalist
design and surveil estate machinery the
sleek lines of these town
more than just aesthetics though every
time I see a skel city I know to prepare
for urban combat often against advance
drones or well outfitted soldiers what's
more each time I find a skel railway or
supply road I know that it will
inevitably lead somewhere
often these locations contain useful
items crucial Intel or sometimes they're
just making the world feel more lived-in
like a winery or a brewery in fact I
have yet to find a scale structure that
doesn't serve some diegetic purpose in
the game world
our OS next layer of environmental
storytelling brings us back to the 20th
century along with its fair share of
gameplay conceits owing to its role as
an American installation during the Cold
War era is laced with bunkers and
nuclear silos each spanning miles
beneath the vibrant surface these
compounds foreshadow close quarters
combat yes along with side quests
involving hazardous nuclear material but
despite the danger they're often
littered with medical supplies and
weapon caches they present a risk reward
factor there yet another part of
breakpoints visual vocabulary that has
gameplay ramifications of its own less
common than the nuclear bunkers yet
useful in their own right
our Oeste jiz of world war ii these
range from the occasional foxhole to a
massive airfield to a crashed fighter
plane more often than not I've found
geographical Intel among the wreckage of
the Pacific Theater further aiding my
efforts to understand this massive
landmass it reinforces the sense of
people being here long before me with
knowledge I can still find useful even
at a time when murderous robots patrol
the shores that sense is amplified in
the next layer when I stumble upon one
of our OS abandoned villages or ancient
ruins while this dilapidated stratum
does make for great window dressing it
also houses some of my favorite side
missions involving the indigenous people
and the descendants who still farmed
fish and live off the land but even
before all this the Cold War the Second
Great War and the people who lived here
first is the oldest aspect of
breakpoints storytelling it's the
archipelago itself it's absolutely
packed with hidden caves and dense
rainforests it's many inlets and foggy
lagoons make for great
amphibious insertion points the terrain
is mountainous draining my energy as I
scramble up steep slopes and down eroded
cliff sides I can almost imagine the
tectonic shifts that created these
ridges the archipelago is the foundation
for Ubisoft Paris's world building and
it creeps into many of breakpoints
gameplay mechanics which is all to say
that breakpoints sense of time the idea
that this world has been around for ages
doesn't just stimulate my imagination it
plays an active role in how I approach
the game it encourages exploration and
rewards me for paying closer attention
somehow despite the fact that aura is a
fictional place and in turn has a
fictional history its past is informing
the present right in front of me a few
months ago during a visit to Ubisoft
Paris art director Benoit Martinez said
something that at the time seemed
innocuous he told me when you name
something you start to care about it
it's only now after 45 hours in Aurora
that I think I understand what he meant
Ghost Recon breakpoint is a severely
flawed game it suffers from sequel bloat
and it added progression systems that at
best are superfluous and at worse
actively detract from the game it's also
narrative ly rough and technically
jarring suffice it to say it has an
identity crisis but when I drop into
this world and take the time to admire
my surroundings I can't help but imagine
the effort it must have taken to give or
OA this sense of history I can't help
but love the way this history actually
effects the way I play the game despite
its frustrations and numerous
shortcomings breakpoint is a master
class in world building both in what we
can see and what we can't
[Music]
you